counter-terror police were waiting at
luton airport for a man they had wanted
to question for seven years
ain davis who's 38 had been deported
from turkey he was arrested and within
hours was charged with terror
crimes he appeared at westminster
magistrate court where his original
arrest warrant was issued in 2015.
davis is charged with possessing a
firearm for terror purposes
and two charges of arranging terrorism
funding it was a 15-minute hearing in
the dock davis was dressed in a prison
issue grey tracksuit he stood briefly
hands behind his back to confirm his
name he wasn't asked how he wanted to
plead to the charges
in syria davis is alleged to have been a
member of a kidnap gang who took western
hostages and killed some of them
the gang's captives nicknamed the four
isis fighters the beatles because of
their english accents
british aid volunteer alan henning was
allegedly beheaded by the gang so too
was another uk volunteer david haynes
davis has always denied being one of the
gang members
he was held in custody and will appear
at the old bailey next month martin
brunt sky news westminster magistrates
court